[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an episode called hi so
from a thai mystery thriller anthology
series girl from nowhere
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
in the opening scene we are introduced
to a prestigious high school in thailand
an affiliate of the school is giving a
tour to a new student named nano she
shows her every classroom and tells nano
the name of the parents who donated for
the rooms to be well-equipped it is
clear that the school runs on donations
from the parents the rich students are
respected while the poor ones are made
fun of nano asks if she is allowed to
pay for one of the rooms in the school
the woman takes her words into
consideration and gives her an old
classroom in return for money nano then
changes the classroom into her personal
office
somewhere else the son of a millionaire
businessman dino brings bags full of
gifts from the uk for his friends he had
gone to visit his parents who lived
there alongside dino toe was also in the
uk for a trip his friends had placed a
bet on who would bring them more gifts
and dino wins the friends unknowingly
compete against each other in terms of
wealth dino is the unsaid leader of the
group and the wealthiest one among them
toe asks him why he didn't meet him when
they were in the same city to which dino
replies that he wanted to spend time
with his family toe is infuriated that
his friends like dino better than him
and is ashamed that he is not as wealthy
it is evident that the group loves dino
just for his money he is aware of this
fact but doesn't seem to mind them using
him the group finds out that a new
student bought an entire classroom for
herself on her first day at school dino
finally has a competitor which he is not
happy about as they talk about nano she
enters the classroom and affirms that
she did in fact buy a room in the school
according to her she is opening her own
company that will help the students get
anything they want in turn for money she
hands them all her business cards
claiming that her company's motto is
that money can buy everything
following that the teacher walks in and
hands them all the results of the last
test dino as usual gets the best grades
out of them meanwhile pop is mad because
he scored only a 2.24 gpa when he had to
cross 3.0 to get a new motorbike from
his father he complains about life being
unfair when nano offers to help him
through her company she brings them to
her office and asks pop for 15 000 baud
for the service since it is pretty cheap
compared to the motorcycle he wants he
decides to give her the money moreover
the group wants to test if she is
telling the truth after confirming that
the money is paid in full nano asks for
his test result and shreds it using a
paper shredder the group is shocked but
then nano prints out a brand new paper
with a better score it looks identical
to the others so pop's parents wouldn't
notice that it's fake he thanks her
happy with the results nano claims that
she can do many other things for them
when asked what kind of things she
smiles and says anything starting that
day her business flourishes quickly a
crowd of students lines up in front of
her office with money asking her for
several favors one day a guy asks nano
to teach his ex-girlfriend a lesson for
cheating on him that evening her new
boyfriend is beaten to death by some
thugs similarly another guy asks for a
girlfriend and gets one thanks to her
company one day after class nano
questions dino why he hadn't asked her
for her services until now she thinks it
is strange that he has no problems in
his life the others claim that he is
filthy rich his parents are never home
and his grades are good since his life
is basically perfect he doesn't need her
help pop even claims that if nano has a
problem she must come to dino because he
has a solution to everything then a girl
named juan mentions that she needs nanos
to help to create a fake teacher's
letter to her parents she wants to go on
an overnight trip outside thailand but
doesn't want her parents to know the
guys like the idea and join in on it
soon they start to plan a trip to japan
when they ask dino to join he claims
that he is tired of taking so many trips
abroad and just wants to be home for now
the others try to convince him to join
them but he doesn't budge nano knows
something about him is off to find out
she suggests they go to dino's house for
dinner since it is a massive villa that
has a swimming pool a home theater a
snucker room a golf room and many other
facilities the group is sure to enjoy
the stay much more than if they travel
abroad however dino doesn't want them in
his house afraid that they will get
drunk and break expensive things in it
pop promises to take responsibility for
all the damages and urges him to invite
them for only a night when he still
doesn't agree they get irritated and ask
him if he considers them as friends dino
doesn't want them to be upset and agrees
to let them stay for a single night
after school ends he gets inside his car
and tells the driver the address to his
house when he reaches there it is
revealed that dino's parents are small
business owners who work hard to send
him to a prestigious school when he
first came into the school he saw how
only the rich kids had friends and lied
to them about being wealthy with time he
had to keep up with the lie by renting
cars to the school and buying them food
from his fake foreign trips this is the
reason why he didn't meet toe during his
last trip to the uk similarly he didn't
want to invite his friends to his
extravagant villa because he doesn't
have one dino's parents are normal
people who want nothing but his
happiness they are unaware of their
son's shenanigans and think that his
generous friends drop him off at home in
their fancy cars every day they never
let dino help them in household work
saying that he should focus on his
studies instead that day dino is tense
because if he doesn't bring his friends
to a massive villa the next day they
will know that he has been lying to them
for several years after coming this far
with his lies he cannot step back he
gets a text from nano in the group chat
asking him what time they should come to
his house dino is thinking of a way to
avoid the topic but his friends start to
talk about what they're going to wear to
the dinner as the conversation proceeds
he cannot say no to them his only way is
to ask nano for help he calls her and
tells her that he wants a house for the
next day when asked why he cannot take
them to his original house he still
insists that he doesn't want them to
break the expensive decorations nano
promises to keep it a secret and agrees
to help him with his problem however she
charges 200 000 baht for the fake
mansion dino doesn't have that much
money to waste for a single night but he
hopes to manage it when his parents are
distracted packing boxes for their
business he steals his father's purse as
he is about to take the card out he
overhears his parents talking about loan
sharks who have been bothering them
every day if they do not pay them 200
000 baht by the next week they have
threatened to kill them the couple is
relieved because they have earned enough
this month to pay off the loans dino
puts the card back after listening to
their conversation but then a vision of
his friends calling him a liar and a
cheat makes him take it out again better
to let his parents get murdered than for
his fake friends to find out that he's
lying when his parents fall asleep he
sneaks out of the house and withdraws
money from the atm on returning home he
encounters his father and is almost
caught the next morning dino wakes up to
his parents on a phone call with the
bank complaining about the theft when
the phone operator suggests someone from
the family must have taken it out dino's
father refuses to believe it dino simply
walks out of the house and meets nano in
front of his mansion for the day when
asked if he likes it he comments that it
is a bit smaller than his house later
the entire group arrives at the house
for dinner dino proudly sits on the sofa
pretending like the expensive cigar and
the in-house golf course is normal to
him then nana suggests they drink
whiskey she is set on calling the maids
to serve them almost as if she has
planned something when the housemaids
arrive in the lobby dino is shocked to
see that it is his parents they have
taken the job to earn more money to pay
off the loan they recognize their son
but do not call him out in front of his
friends dino can hardly say anything
when nano suggests they look at his
parents pictures on the internet on
finding them she also comments that he
resembles the house servants more than
he resembles his parents dino's mother
helps him claiming that he looks like
his grandfather following that they go
to the dining room and are served a full
course restaurant style meal when they
drink the whiskey they realize that it
is actually fruit juice pop lashes out
at dino's father calling him an idiot
the man apologizes and says that they
shouldn't be drinking at their age this
makes pop even more furious he
emphasizes that dino's father is just a
servant asking him to act like one after
being insulted the man simply serves
them the drink to stir the awkwardness
nano suggests they smoke weed as well
dino tries to stop them saying that his
parents might find out but the group
doesn't listen to fit in he also smokes
while his parents watch him in
disappointment moments later pop asks
for wine but dino's father refuses to
serve it since they have already had too
much to drink pop threatens to get him
fired and insults him yet again scared
of him dino's mother serves them the
wine even when the father disagrees she
accidentally drops it on juan who
accuses her of doing it on purpose pop
gets up from his seat ready to fight
them but dino stops him he calms
everyone down and asks his friends to go
to another room for a minute he is left
alone with his parents but he walks away
when his mother tries to talk to him
following that the group goes to a study
room while complaining about the rude
servants they want to do something fun
to lighten the mood when nano shows them
a revolver she found on a shelf pop
loads a single bullet and bets two
hundred thousand baht on the person who
gets shot the group joins in and bets
two 200 000 baht each the person to get
shot in the arm will receive more than 1
million baud so dino doesn't want to
give up the chance pop goes first but
isn't shot similarly three of them press
the trigger with the gun to their arm
but they do not get shot either when it
is nano's turn she points the gun at her
head but she is not shot either
at last it is dino's turn he is about to
shoot himself when his father stops him
he yells at the kids to be more
responsible with their lives because
their parents love them an enraged pop
hits him with a golf club and knocks him
out before the group can react dino's
mother interferes and begins to scold
them pop hits her with the back of the
revolver and knocks her out as well dino
freezes in shock but he still doesn't do
anything to help his parents nano starts
to laugh maniacally while the others
look at the maids in horror in the
following scene dino walks to his house
to see that his parents are having
dinner their faces are covered in
injuries that were inflicted by pop they
do not talk about the events of the day
and call him to have dinner a flashback
shows us that as they came back to
consciousness they were given 3 500 000
baht to keep their mouth shut in the
last scene we see the family having
dinner peacefully the camera pans
towards the bag of money they received
earlier
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications thank you for watching